on the car bombs and blasts in Moscow
killing vocal Advocates of the invasion
of Ukraine to the most recent
cross-border raids inside Russia's
bilgarad region there is clear evidence
of armed resistance to Vladimir Putin's
War the anti-kremlin fighters Behind
these attacks are a loose collection of
disparate groups with Divergent
political views and ideologies but
United by one common goal
to ensure the collapse of the Russian
regime as quickly as possible this Mast
anti-putin gunman told us CBS News sent
written questions to our partisan group
claiming to be operating on Russian soil
the fighters heavily disguised say they
derail the train in briansk earlier this
month their most successful action to
date